well we're talking about empowering
women getting back to work that's the
goal
of the united way of southern nevada and
their annual suit drive
bianca holman is live with how you can
help and get involved tell us more
bianca good morning
hey good morning sherry we're live here
at the united way of southern nevada's
office here on flamingo and you know
sherry when you look good
you feel good when you feel good you do
good and you perform great and that's
what this is all about you can see these
racks of clothes that have already been
donated for this annual suit drive
and i'm joined by kyle with the southern
nevada organization so tell me united
way of southern nevada organization so
tell us more about this suit drive that
you all have been doing for a while now
well it's been going on for 13 years
it was started by a group of dynamic
women within united way that are all
donors it's called women united
and they determined that there were so
many wonderful programs
getting women back to work in town but
the women didn't have suits
they didn't have professional dress and
as you all know
clothes make the person right so it's
very much an empowerment
for a woman to have not she doesn't just
get a suit but she gets shoes
purses she gets a full outfit with
accessories and as you know walking
through that door is the hardest part
but walking with confidence and knowing
that you're properly attired for the
first impression
makes all the difference in the world so
we partner with our
organizations here in town who are have
women workforce
opportunity programs and they all
get suits and it's just a phenomenal
thing and we've been doing it for 13
years
wow that is awesome and again you've had
a great turnout so far
so whether it's suits dresses shoes
accessories
purses you need a good bag to go with it
and i saw some case bait bags over there
so
go through your closets do what you can
go through i know you're about to bring
out your winter clothes it's time to go
through that storage unit
and really bring these donations here
because so many women need it and of
course we're going to have those details
you can bring them here
drive through you it's contactless they
don't have to touch you you know we're
making sure we're staying safe and
everything like that so
come here to their office to drop off
those clothes and there's accessories to
help women in need that are trying to
get back on their feet
we're going to send it back to you guys
in the studio hey bianca are they taking
jewelry
are you all taking jewelry yes yes
absolutely
especially in the days of zoom but yes
yes
wonderful so some great pearls a nice
bracelet send it on over
bring it here to their location on
flamingo awesome all right thanks bianca
i love that program they do every year
it's amazing they help so
many women and when when you look good
you feel good and when you feel good you
do
i love that whole thing that's awesome
yeah bianca good stuff
make it